En premier nous avons Steve Keen, à ma gauche, que la plupart d'entre vous connaissent
Steve est professeur et chercheur à l'Institute for Strategy, Resilience and Security à l'University College de Londres
et Steve va expliquer pourquoi certains de nos modèles économiques les mieux considérés sur le changement climatiques ne sont pas dignes de confiance
et pourquoi nous ne devons pas nous appuyer dessus pour prendre des décisions pour l'avenir
et il parlera ensuite d'autres solutions
Nous savons que le prix Nobel d'économie va de nouveau être attribué, l'an dernier il avait été attribué à deux personnes
dont l'un est William Nordhaus pour "avoir intégré le changement climatique dans une analyse macro-économique de long terme"
et ceci est une slide clef du discours que Nordhaus a fait lorsqu'il a reçu le prix Nobel
on voit on certain nombre de trajectoires qui représentent différentes températures entre aujourd'hui et 2150
et il a appelé l'une d'entre elles "optimale"
celle qui donne une augmentation de température de 4°C par rapport à la période pré-industrielle d'ici à 2140
"optimale"
4°C de plus qu'à la période pré-industrielle.
Comment peut-on considérer une augmentation de la température de 4°C par rapport à la période pré-industrielle comme "optimale" ?
La logique était que cela minimisait à la fois le coût de réductions des émissions de gaz à effet de serre et le coût du changement climatique
Il dit que si nous ne réduisons pas du tout les émissions de gaz à effet de serre,
c'est-à-dire que nous laissons le climat suivre sa pente avec les émissions de CO2 actuelles
et tous les polluants que nous envoyons dans l'atmosphère
alors la température sera supérieure à +6°C par rapport à la période pré-industrielle
et l'impact négatif sur la valeur actuelle nette serait de $23000 milliards, soit un peu plus que l'économie américaine
Le coût de réductions des émissions de gaz à effet de serre est donc nul.
Si maintenant nous optons pour une réduction optimale de nos émissions
qui limiterait l'augmentation de température à 4°C par rapport à la période pré-industrielle
l'impact négatif serait de $15000 milliards
soit moins que la taille de l'économie américaine actuelle
coût de la réduction des émissions : $3000 milliards
Voici les calculs
6 mois avant qu'il ne fasse ce discours
un vrai scientifique du climat
Will Steffen
décrivait l'hypothèse d'une augmentation de température de 4°C comme ceci :
les tropiques sont inhabitables
et la punchline et ici en bas : la capacité maximale de la Terre est d'un milliard d'êtres humains.
aujourd'hui nous sommes 7,5 milliards.
Alors, expliquez-moi comment ces deux visions du futur sont compatibles.
Ce que je pensais, avant que je commence à lire ces deux contenus en détail
c'est que les économistes appliquaient une grosse ristourne à des analyses d'impact similaires
J'ai découvert que ce n'était pas ça.
En fait, ils faisaient leurs propres estimations
en utilisant un certain nombre de méthodes, dont la plus absurde est celle-ci :
ils utilisaient les variations mondiales actuelles de température et de PIB
en pensant pouvoir les utiliser pour estimer l'impact du changement climatique
C'est l'un des articles clefs qui défend cette prétendue recherche empirique
Ils partent du postulat qu'on peut déduire des variations dans le temps à partir de variations géographiques de  l'activité économique en fonction du climat
Ça a l'air malin. En fait c'est complètement stupide.
Ce qu'ils ont fait, c'est prendre des données sur le PIB et les température actuels, principalement aux Etats-Unis
et ils ont trouvé une relation quadratique faible entre température et PIB.
ils ont ensuite postulé qu'une relation similaire s'appliquerait tandis qu'on augmenterait massivement l'énergie solaire captée via les gaz à effet de serre.
Ils appellent ça l'approche statistique (ils lui donnent un certain nombre de noms)
Celui-ci est le premier article à le faire, et il est loin d'être le seul.
Il dit que les fonctions de réponse au climat sont quadratiques
que des pays qui sont aujourd'hui plus froids vont en bénéficier
et que les pays qui sont plus chauds vont, eux, en souffrir
et avec l'analyse transversale, en mettant toutes les données ensemble, ils montraient qu'avec une augmentation de température - de 3°C dans le cas présent
apporterait un bénéfice annuel de $145 milliards d'euros par ans
Et cela est devenu une donnée de référence que Nordhaus utilise pour sa fonction de dommage, qui est simplement une fonction quadratique.
C'est la différence de température par rapport à la période pré-industrielle au carré, multipliée par un coefficient
parce qu'il devait déterminer la valeur de ce coefficient.
Et donc, en utilisant ce genre de données et des données aussi discutables, voici la données de référence de Mendelssohn
une augmentation du PIB de 0,1% fournie par une augmentation de température de 2,5°C
D'autres se fondent sur le même raisonnement
Et voilà celle de Nordhaus de 1994 qui supposait le même type de relation.
Et le coefficient
a été à nouveau réduit dans les articles les plus récents
le coefficient dans cette quadratique est de 0,00227
Ce qui signifie que l'augmentation d'un degré de la température par rapport à la période pré-industrielle causerait une baisse de 0,227% du PIB mondial
avant ristourne, soit dit en passant
il n'y a pas de ristourne, c'est simplement le dommage réel qu'ils anticipent
2°C engendreront moins d'1% de baisse du PIB
4°C n'engendreront qu'un peu plus de 3,6% de baisse du PIB
et même 10°C n'engendreraient qu'une chute de 23% du PIB
par rapport à ce que cela aurait été sans aucun réchauffement climatique.
Alors, ces conclusions sont valide si et seulement si
le postulat qui veut que la variation géographique que nous observons aujourd'hui
sera la même au fil du temps avec la très forte augmentation de l'énergie retenue dans la biosphère
grâce à la présence croissante de gaz à effet de serre
J'ai pris part à un échange assez âpre avec l'un des économistes qui a écrit ce rapport du GIEC il y a quelques années, William Tol
oh, Richard Tol, mes excuses
dans lequel il disait, c'est un de ses traits caractéristiques
"10 degrés Kelvin c'est moins que la différence de température entre l'Alaska et le Maryland, blablabla"
et "le climat n'est pas une facteur de revenu primaire"
On parle de quelqu'un qui participe à la  rédaction des rapports du GIEC
Puis un météorologue est intervenu dans la discussion
Et a dit qu'un climat mondial plus chaud de 10 degrés qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas, mais pas du tout, mettre 10 degrés en plus partout.
La réponse de Tol à cela a été
que ça n'avait rien à voir, que des gens prospèrent sur des climats très différents
et que le déterminisme climatique n'avait donc aucun fondement empirique.
Et il a fini par dire que si l'on ne peut prouver que la relation n'existe pas dans l'espace, alors on ne peut pas soutenir avec assurance qu'elle existe dans le temps.
Ce qu'ils ont fait, c'est qu'ils ont pris le PIB à deux endroits
pas seulement aux Etats-Unis, et les ont comparés
à niveau d'énergie dans la biosphère constant - on ne regarde pas le changement dans le temps, d'accord ?
Ce que va faire le changement climatique, c'est d'augmenter très fortement le niveau d'énergie dans la biosphère
ce qui va complètement chambouler le climat actuel
et la vie humaine en conséquence
Une relation PIB-température à l'échelle locale ne vous donne aucune espèce d'information sur l'effet du réchauffement climatique
Je vais vous donner un exemple linéaire, uniquement pour les besoins de la démonstration
Supposons - je n'y crois pas, c'est uniquement pour les besoins de la démonstration -
supposons que la température soit une somme linéaire de la température globale donnée par notre localisation dans la zone habitable de notre étoile
à laquelle on ajouterait des déviations locales en fonction de la position sur la surface de la planète
et supposons qu'il y ait également un lien entre température et PIB
l'hypothèse que je fais de cette façon, c'est que le PIB par habitant est fonction de deux températures :
la température globale donnée par la position dans la zone habitable de l'étoile
et par les gaz à effet de serre (période pré-industrielle)
plus les déviations locales
ce qui donne alpha1 x température globale + alpha2 x température locale
Faisons-le pour la Floride : la déviation locale aux Etats-Unis est de 7 degrés par rapport au reste des Etats-Unis
pour le Dakota c'est 10 degrés en-dessous
ensuite vous faites un calcul : vous les soustrayez
vous obtenez une relation en disant que la différence entre les deux est de 17 fois la valeur du coefficient de la variation de température locale.
vous avez nullifié votre variation de température globale
vous pouvez ensuite résoudre alpha2, en donner une estimation
vous n'avez aucune information sur alpha1, alors vous supposez qu'alpha1 = alpha2
C'est scandaleusement stupide.
Et pas seulement stupide dans un exercice académique.
Cela menace l'existence de la société humaine.
Si quelqu'un est en mesure de détruire le capitalisme, ce sont les auteurs de ces recherches.
C'est comme d'avoir, et je voudrais en donner une illustration visuelle, ce serait comme d'avoir des informations nord-sud à propos d'une montagne,
rien sur l'est-ouest, et de dire à des randonneurs, puisque c'est plat, que l'est-ouest est sans danger parce que nord-ouest est plat
et vous vous retrouvez au bord d'El Capitan
C'est à peu près aussi intelligent que ce que les économistes ont fait dans ce cas-ci.
et ces "données" de climat, fatalement irréalistes,
ont été calibrées sur des fonctions de dommage tout aussi irréalistes.
C'est toute la difficulté de saisir quelque chose dont nous n'avons pas fait l'expérience
Je voulais donc dire qu'on peut utiliser leurs modèles et leurs postulats, les fonctions de dommage quadratiques
pour examiner des phénomènes dont nous avons fait l'expérience, en tant qu'espèce :
des températures plus faibles qu'aujourd'hui, la dernière période glaciaire.
Quand vous revenez aux enregistrements de température, vous vous apercevez que la dernière période glaciaire
était environ 4 degrés sous la moyenne entre 1951 et 1980.
A quoi ressemblait la planète à ce moment-là ?
Et que prédirait la fonction de dommage de Nordhaus, si au lieu de réchauffement climatique, nous connaissions un refroidissement climatique ?
Eh bien, il y a 20 mille ans, il faisait en moyenne 4 degrés plus froid, et voici à quoi ressemblait la planète.
Prédiction de Nordhaus ? Cela réduirait le PIB de 3,6%
Il mérite qu'on se moque de lui, pas qu'on lui donne un prix Nobel, d'accord ?
C'est dire, sur la base de l'économie, qu'il n'y a pas à s'en préoccuper, et aux politiques qu'il n'y a rien à craindre. De la foutaise à l'état pur.
A nouveau, juste pour enfoncer le clou
New York serait 1km sous la glace
ça n'affectera pas le PIB de plus de 3,6%?
Il est tout bonnement impossible de faire des extrapolations sur ce monde avec nos données actuelles, or c'est ce qu'ils ont fait.
Alors pourquoi ont-ils ignoré les points de bascule ? Ils en parlent tout le temps, mais on ne les retrouve jamais dans leurs fonctions, en tout cas pas dans celles de Nordhaus,
et en fait, il les a rendues encore moins capables de gérer des points de bascule dans ses articles les plus récents
C'est parce qu'il n'est pas possible de faire des analyses coût-bénéfice quand il y a des discontinuités.
La réponse des économistes a donc été d'ignorer les points de bascule.
Ce que le scientifique du climat dit, (ce qu'il fait beaucoup plus poliment que moi,
j'espère qu'ils vont faire comme moi et être aussi grossiers que nécessaire pour être entendus sur ce terrain)
c'est d'abandonner les analyses coût-bénéfice.
Steffen a publié un article commun avec 16 autres scientifiques tout récemment
et ils ont dit très modérément que la façon contemporaine d'orienter le développement
fondée sur la croyance en des changements graduels et incrémentaux ne sera vraisemblablement pas adéquate pour gérer cette trajectoire
- je dirais plutôt : certainement pas.
Ils n'imaginent même pas que cette trajectoire est celle sur laquelle nous sommes engagés.
Ma position, après avoir lu ces données, après avoir lu le rapport du GIEC
c'est que nous devrions retirer les économistes du GIEC.
Et à défaut, au moins de nommer des économistes non-mainstream, qui ne feraient pas des postulats aussi stupides.
Des gens comme moi, Campiglio, Garrett, Giraud, Grasselli... nous sommes un certain nombre à produire des travaux non-orthodoxes sur ces sujets
et nous ne serions pas d'accord avec ces postulats.
Et de demander à des scientifiques du climat de vérifier ce qu'ils produisent.
Et comme nous ne faisons pas cela, ce qui se passe, c'est
le déni du changement climatique, ou pour mieux dire, la trivialisation du changement climatique
et l'utilisation du GIEC pour justifier cette trivialisation.
Vous connaissez tous ici Bjorn Lomborg
voici quelques déclarations qu'il a faites : "Le lauréat actuel du Nobel montre que la solution optimale est de modérer les taxes sur les CO2 pour atteindre 3,5°"
Il cite encore le GIEC en montrant ces fonctions de dommages.
"6°C équivaudrait probablement à une perte de PIB de l'ordre de 6 à 12%"
Et il cite le GIEC, il cite des économistes quand il tient ces discours.
Et il s'en prend aux étudiants qui se mobilisent, ceux d'Extinction Rébellion.
Il dit ensuite vous voyez le problème, le GIEC dit que son impact serait plus faible que la plupart des autres facteurs.
Regardons ça de plus près, il cite bien le GIEC
"Dans la plupart des secteurs économiques, l'impact du changement climatique sera faible en comparaison avec d'autres facteurs" - dont la population (preuves moyennes, consensus fort).
Tout le groupe réuni des économistes
se sont mis d'accord entre eux et croient à ce postulat stupide
qui veut que des données sur la température et le PIB actuels
doivent être utilisés pour prédire l'impact du changement climatique.
Et vous ne serez pas surpris en découvrant le nom de l'un des principaux auteurs.
Nous devrions utiliser les données des scientifiques du climat, dont le travail de Steffen et d'autres pour identifier les points de bascule
dont le premier, bien sûr, est déjà derrière nous : la glace de mer de l'Arctique en hiver.
et la réaction en chaîne qu'il engendrera fera que nous ne pourrons pas rester à des niveaux de température que ces économistes jugent inoffensif.
Nous avons besoins de modèles dans lesquels l'énergie joue un rôle fondamental.
Or, aucun des modèles néo-classiques, aucun des modèles néo-keynésiens ne prend correctement en compte l'énergie.
J'ai commencé ce travail avec Grasselli et Garrett
et lorsque nous leur faisons processer cela et que nous avons à la fois les comportements cycliques et économiques qui suivent un effondrement écnomique
et une illustration particulièrement simple d'un défaut de ressources.
Elle est simple et stylisée, mais elle est déjà plus réaliste que ce que Nordhaus a produit, en cela qu'elle inclut les contraintes de ressources qui sont absentes du travail que font ces soi-disant économistes du climat.
Vous savez que je suis critique vis-à-vis de l'économie mainstream, ce n'est un secret pour personne
mais ici, mes critiques ne dépendent pas du rejet du modèle de croissance de Ramsey ou ce genre de choses
je n'en suis même pas à ce niveau de critique-là !
Là, ce sont leurs postulats ineptes.
Aucun économiste classique qui se respecte ne devrait valoriser ce que produisent ces gens
et d'autres avant moi se sont manifesté et ont dit que c'était bourré de défauts
quasiment inutile, pire qu'inutile
ils nous distraient de l'important défi devant nous et il est temps que nous leur fermions le clapet.
Merci